Hi, My name is Ayush
Sharma, and I'm
majoring in computer science.
And my work is called
"Privacy Email."
So companies and organizations
are collecting more of our data
than ever before.
We have tried ways of
privatizing the data by naive
techniques, such as
redacting the sensitive info,
something called key anonymity.
These techniques
over time have been
shown to not be very
effective and in fact are
quite easily breakable.
The golden standard for
privacy is called something
called differential privacy.
So consider two data
sets that are neighboring
such that there's one user
present in the data set
that's not in the other one.
The intuitive notion
of differential privacy
is that what's the difference
of privacy of this user by being
in the data sets versus
not being in a data set,
and can you optimize for that?
This is where our work comes
in, because there is currently
no framework or
library that can use
this technique of differential
privacy for an enabled data
analysts to use it
in their own work.
In "Privacy Email,"
we provide a library
a tool box where data
analysts can simply
ask for their parameters
to be set and then
choose the noising mechanisms to
achieve the result of privacy.
What happens that you start
with the sensitive data, can
run the black box
algorithm, which
is written by the
analyst, get the result,
and then we will add the
sensitive noise to the data
and get the private result.
Bear in mind that we can control
the amount of privacy here
and the epsilon parameter
of the privacy budget.
And this all works seamlessly
with existing infrastructure
written in Spark
and [? Scala. ?]
In terms of results, we
notice that we can generate
linear regression results and
can get a plus in distribution
from the result as expected.
And we were able
to quite narrow it
down and provide better utility
without having much overhead.
Thank you.